كيف هو وضع
يدك
الان كيف هو وضع تم استهدافك انت و سامر
ابو دقه كيف هو وضعك الصحي
الان اولا وقبل كل شيء نحمد الله على كل
حال الوضع الصحي نتمنى ان يكون جيدا ولكن
على مستوى اليد يعني هي تحتاج حقيقه الى
تدخل الى تخطيط عصب وتدخل جراحي فائق
الدقه واختصاصي الى نحو كبير وهو الامر
الذي لا يوجد في قطاع غزه وغير متوفر لا
من حيث الاختصاص ولا من حيث المعدات
اللازمه والاجهزه اللازمه لذلك خصوصا في
اوقات الحروب بالتاكيد وهذا بالتاكيد يجعل
يعني مهمه استشفائها وعلاجها مهمه في شبه
مستحيله في قطاع غزه نتمنى ان تنقشع هذه
الغمه وتتوقف هذه الحرب وبالتالي ان نجد
فرصه لعلاج هذه اليد لتعود تعمل كما كانت
في السابق ولكن بكل الاحوال بغض النظر عن
هذه الاصابه او غيرها طالما اننا قادرون
على الوقوف او الجلوس امام عدسه الكاميرا
وا امتشاق هذا الميكروفون فبالتاكيد لن
نتردد ولن نتاخر ابدا ابدا ابدا